oh
lord is he eating soup on a bench
alone tom
fine come on rubber band come with us
what what no arguing for no super events
you didn't what what
what is happening right now hey there he
is good to see you again mikey hey think
fast i brought you something
oh nuts thank you
flaming snake ate all the nuts you
brought me too nice to humiliate
oh hello hi you look like a piece of
crap
are you eleanor dude you're like a
legend in the bad place
check this out huh you're right
that's pretty great right trevor do you
know what caused this mistake cause i
cannot figure it out no we're
stumped but uh don't sweat it champ
she's definitely one of ours so we'll
just
roll on out and you can get back to uh
putting rainbows up your butt or
whatever you do here
okay let's hit it sweetheart we got a
long ride what
right now trevor for decency's sake let
her have some goodbyes
oh god good people are the worst okay uh
30 minutes we got to get back for the
bachelor i'm gonna be pissed if i missed
the rose ceremony
soundtrack to pulp fiction soundtrack to
singles
soundtrack to gross point blank why do
you have so many soundtracks
oh well uh i kind of look at it like
it's your favorite director's making a
mixtape just for you
oh oh here's something
benji's cool time summer jams mix oh no
i
probably don't want to listen to that
yes i want to listen to you i want to
listen to it
april shoot
oh here i go here i go here i go
really don't judge me okay data had
never felt anything before
but captain picard couldn't help but
note the smile
that crept over his mechanical but
life-like
face i'm gonna murder you i understand
just one second
as they walked down the hall into the
bridge
whoa it's moving it's moving what
yes finally
no no no no no no no
what no we're out of gas
this is gonna make a primo dump later on
well that looks delicious what is that
oh it's tom yum gong soup
it reminds me of when i was in thailand
rescuing victims of human trafficking
oh that sounds so good i mean um the
soup not the
human trafficking oh and i think your
grilled eggplant looks so good
should we put these
i can't believe you thought you could
pretend to be real eleanor she's like a
perfect ball of light and you're like a
wet pile of mulch someone made a person
out of wet mulch and leaves and like
dead slugs and that's you
chris i'm dying
i was dying earlier today and then i
died
now i'm dead i had to cancel a date with
shot em all my
tweet and i really like her do you think
she'll still like me
not that i'm dead what is this it's food
poisoning
i have it too i did not sleep for one
second last night
and i cracked the bottom of the toilet
bowl god don't say that
has anybody talked to tom i can't even
imagine what that tiny little man must
be feeling like
i have voided more than tom's body
weight in the last 12 hours alone
he might have just disappeared off the
earth we need to call him
we must reach out to him
i can't do it
ben extension 7820.
hello mindy my name is bee i'm from the
good place and welcome
to your first day in the afterlife
what's up idiot sorry i'm late babe
hey are you pregnant that's not possible
congrats
yeah so mindy look you mostly sucked but
then you did this one
good thing i mean i still think we
should get you they didn't but
neither did we a compromise was made the
neighborhood you were in now
by yourself you submitted a list of
things you wanted the good place
provided those things yeah and the bad
place made some modifications
we got you your favorite beer yeah but
it's always warm
on your jukebox you'll find every song
ever sung
yeah by the eagles and it's only the
live versions
also there's some spoken word poetry
from william shatner
it's deeply terrible you get the idea
welcome to eternal mediocrity
welcome to the media place so what's up
what's your deal you single what's going
on
welcome to you heard with perd i'm perd
hapley
the story of our guest today is that
they are from the department of parks
and recreation
ben wyatt and tom haverford what up perd
big fan
me too perd what up the thing about this
first question is
i'd like to ask you about the harvest
festival perd it's gonna be amazing
carnival rides games sweden is even
building
a plus-sized roller coaster for some of
pawnee's obese thrill-seekers
you must be this wide to ride wow that's
gonna be a pretty big roller coaster
yep hey guys how'd it go
well there were some sticky moments
let's go to the videotape ah
look who hasn't had gay thoughts who
are you okay yeah i'm fine i'm fine i
mean you know sometimes i feel like i
might need glasses
is there a bird in here i swear i keep
seeing a bird
in the studio he was fine until bird
started asking about the boy mayor's
stuff what's wrong with you you look
psychotic
i was 18 when i was elected mayor okay
so excuse me for that
cindy eckert had just turned me down for
senior prom do you know how that feels i
should call her
i should i no i shouldn't and i'm not
going to and i'm proud of myself for
that
and then he talked about feeling up
cindy eckert for the first time for
about five minutes
and then the show ended as did our
careers and probably harvest fest
boom sadness that's the one so
ellie baby brainstorm we should get a
house me you tahani jason we should all
go in together on a place roomies
zombies that is
technically an idea i think it would be
soups fun we could play pranks on each
other for my vlog we could do one of
those ice bucket challenges that i
sent you or maybe just a harlem shake i
like to
cook and i have been dying to experiment
with jamaican food man
i like a jamaican food listen to the
reggae and smoke
the joints it's a jamaican accent
man did you buy anything for yourself
today yeah i got this pack of socks
plain white socks that's not a treat
donna
get me away from him maybe this is our
version of treat yourself day and he
needs to do his version what are you
talking about
why if you could blow big money on one
thing not sock money
what would it be
oh my god oh my god oh my god this is a
whole new level of nerd
you're right this is ridiculous what am
i doing wait no no no no no i mean that
in a good way ben
listen to me you're part of the treat
yourself team now okay
if that costume somehow makes you happy
you're gonna buy it
and you're gonna wear it out of the
store okay you're gonna treat yourself
yeah you know what i'm gonna do that i'm
gonna
i'm gonna treat myself thanks you guys
thank you
i really needed this
uh batman's crying what's wrong
out with it i was seeing a woman
for a while and then we stopped seeing
each other
pretty recently that's why you've been
off your game
sorry dog you're a catch wyatt
you're gonna be okay there's chicken
heads everywhere ben
chicken head's all around the small
you're gonna find one and you're gonna
be great but for now why don't you let
it out treat yourself to a good cry
one question though yeah
why so serious
the internet's not working ben we need
your help
guys i've told you how to do it you just
unplug the router and then you plug it
back in again
i guess i'll do it
still not working well give it a minute
good
okay it's working
you